in this video we're going to go through
an Algebra 1 final exam review we're
going to go through 40 questions and
this is aim more for the honors student
or the advanced student or just students
that want to kind of test themselves to
make sure that they're really on top of
their algebra one game if any of these
problems are really challenging you
might want to go back and check my
regular Algebra 1 final exam review and
go through those problems as well so
let's dive into this video we're going
to go through these questions see if you
can pause the video and do some of the
problems on your own and we'll of course
go through them together and see how
many of these you can get right so let's
dive into the first example it says you
have 98 feet of fencing to protect a
rectangular Garden you want the garden
to be two and a half times
long as it is wide what are the width
and the length of this Garden okay so
story problems sometimes make algebra a
little bit challenging and so what you
want to do is of course you want to draw
a diagram and in this case we have a
rectangle regular Garden we want the
length to be two and a half times as
wide as it the garden is so let's call
the the width of the garden W it's good
to use that first letter and then the
length is going to be 2.5 times W and
remember these two lengths are going to
be the same these two widths are the
same so if we know that we have 98 feet
of fencing that's really referring to
the perimeter of the garden so all we
have to do is add up all the sides and
set it equal to that perimeter of 98
feet so let's see we've got 5 6 7. so
this is really 7 W is equal to 98. if we
divide both sides by 7 you can see that
W is coming out to
14 and so now if we put 14 back in we
know that the width is 14 feet
and the length is going to be two and a
half times 14 which is let's see that's
28 plus another seven that's going to be
35 feet
and you got it okay let's go to example
number two
it says a vehicle is moving at 40 miles
per hour a second vehicle heading the
same direction is two miles behind the
first vehicle and it's traveling 70
miles per hour so faster right how long
will it take for it to catch up to that
first vehicle so kind of visualize this
here's the first car it's ahead but it's
going slower here's the second car it's
behind but it's going faster right so
they're both moving eventually the
second car is going to catch up to the
first car just because it's traveling
faster
sometimes when you do these problems
it's helpful to make a little table and
I'll show you what you can do is you can
say rate times time is equal to distance
and let's just call this vehicle number
one and vehicle number two and let's
just kind of make a little chart like
this
now the rate of the first vehicle we set
is 40 and it's been traveling for T
hours let's say and then the distance
that it travels is 40 times T so that's
40t the second vehicle is traveling 70
miles an hour it's also traveling for T
time right and that's going to be
traveling a distance of 70 t
but we want vehicle one the distance
that that vehicle has traveled to be the
same distance that vehicle 2 has
traveled so what we're going to do for
vehicle one it's traveled
40 times t plus it's two miles ahead so
it's already traveled an additional two
miles and we want the second vehicle to
Traverse that same distance so that's
going to be equal to 70t
so now we've got our equation all we
have to do is solve let's go ahead and
subtract 40t from both sides
so you can see that 2 is equal to 30 T
and if we divide both sides by 30 you
can see that t is equal to 1 15 of an
hour now 15th of an hour that's going to
be
four minutes so you can say it's four
minutes it'll take to catch up or it
could say 1 15 of an hour and you got it
okay go ahead and pause the video see if
you can try number three and four and
we'll go through them together number
three you can see we have an absolute
value equation so how do we solve an
absolute value equation well remember
whatever is inside of this absolute
value before we took the absolute value
it could have been positive it could
have been negative but when you take
that absolute value it always turns it
into a positive value so working
backwards what we do is we say
this quantity in the absolute value 2x
plus 5 could equal
positive 6X it could also equal
the opposite of 6X or negative times 6X
all we have to do now is solve these two
equations and let's see what we get so
if we subtract 2x from both sides
that gives us 5 is equal to 4X and if we
divide both sides by 4 you can see that
X is coming out to 5 4. in this equation
you can see we have a negative 6X if we
subtract 2x from both sides
that's going to give us 5 is equal to
negative 8X and if we divide both sides
by negative 8 you can see that X is
coming out to
negative 5 8.
now what makes this problem a little bit
challenging aside from you know the fact
that sometimes students forget about the
the two scenarios is you want to go back
and check so for example if I put 5 4 in
here 2 times 5 4 is let's see 10 4.
plus 24 is 34 and if I put 5 4 here I
also get 34 so you can see that's that's
a good answer over here now if I put
negative 5 8 in
6 times negative 5 8 is negative 30 over
8 but when we take an absolute value
it's always going to yield a positive
quantity which means that this is
actually an extraneous solution so this
is actually false so here we're just
getting one answer so you always want to
go back and check with these absolute
value equations to see if the answer
works now in example number four here
see if you can do this one you're
solving for x so how would you do that
one
well what makes this problem a little
bit challenging is that you've got an X
in this group as well as this group so
how are we going to get that X by itself
how are we going to rewrite this literal
equation to solve for x well what I
would do is I would get the everything
that has an X
on one side of the equation
and everything that doesn't have an x on
the other side of the equation
okay as long as we do it to both sides
we're keeping it balanced so you can see
now we have three x minus 4y X the twos
cancel the 4y X's cancel and we have 5y
plus two so here what we need to do is
we need to factor out this x because
we're trying to get that X by itself so
it's like doing the distributive
property backwards instead of
Distributing the X in we're dividing it
out
and now all we have to do to get this x
by itself is instead of multiplying by
the quantity 3 minus 4y we'll divide
both sides by 3 minus 4y
and you can see that cancels and we have
X is equal to this quantity right here
5y Plus 2. all divided by 3 minus 4y and
you got it okay see if you can pause the
video and do number five and six a lot
of times students ask me you know when
are we ever going to use this math in in
real life and those same students
oftentimes are the ones that absolutely
hate story problems or word problems and
you know I try to encourage them and say
well you know the the story problems the
word problems they're trying to show you
in the book and in these problems that
you do this is an application of math in
real life so try to get comfortable with
story problems I'm sure if you're
watching this video you're probably
already pretty good at them but try
number five so it says you can work out
at a gym for six dollars per day or you
can buy a monthly membership for 79 for
the month write an inequality to solve
for how many quote unquote day passes
that you can buy for it to be a better
deal than buying a monthly pass then
solve that inequality so how would you
do that one well sometimes what's
helpful is to write like a little word
in it quality what I mean by that is you
could start off by saying hmm when would
the day passes
be cheaper or better deal right so less
money than the monthly membership
okay so you make a little word
inequality then you say well how much
does it cost per day well it's six
dollars times the number of days that
you go right and you want that to be
less than the monthly membership which
is 79 dollars
and that's basically it so now to solve
it you have to just divide both sides by
six
and you can see the number of day passes
would have to be less than
13 and 1 6. now you really can't buy one
sixth of a day pass right because
they're selling them one per day so I
would when I write this problem you want
to kind of interpret this information
and you say hmm the number of days would
have to be uh
13 days
or less
for it to be a better deal and so that's
the kind of sentence that you'd want to
write put in your units Etc which in
this case are the number of days okay
for number six now it says write an
absolute value deviation inequality
you're looking for a job with a required
number of weekly work hours of at least
20 hours and no more than 30 hours so
here we're switching to an absolute
value deviation inequality and what I
like to do sometimes with these problems
is draw a little sketch so you can see
like here's 20 hours that you're working
a week here's 30 hours you want it to be
at least 20 so equal to 20
or greater but no more than so it could
equal 30 or be less than so basically
we're in between 20 and 30 hours
what you want to do is you want to find
that halfway point which is 25 and you
can see that from 25 to 30 that's 5 from
25 to 20 that's five that's like our
deviation like how far off of that
Target value that we are so what I would
do here is I would say x minus this
target value of 25
has to be less than or equal to meaning
less than like closer to or equal to 5
units away so that's our absolute value
deviation inequality now to solve it if
you were not given all this and you're
sort of given this how do you solve what
you can do when it's a less than or less
than or equal to you can put this
quantity here in the middle
and have it less than or equal to 5 and
greater than or equal to negative 5. and
then to solve it you're trying to get
that variable by itself in the middle so
you can add 25 to the left middle and
right
and you can see now we're getting 20 is
less than or equal to X is less than or
equal to 30 and that's what we have
graphed here so when you think of less
than it's like closer to if it was
greater than right that's like further
away and look for that middle value
That's What I Call like the target value
the minus means like the difference or
the distance between that Target value
okay and you want that distance to be
less than five units closer so great job
on that if you're able to get that one
okay see if you can do number seven and
number eight for number seven it says
the function C of x equals 2x plus 1
represents how much it costs to buy X
books at a library use book sale with a
canvas bag to put them in how many books
can you buy with twenty dollars so how
would you do that problem
well what they're testing us on here in
this problem is really functions and
function notation and so when you think
of C of X that's really like the output
that's the cost so we could say for
twenty dollars we can buy
that's how much we have to spend that's
the total cost and this is equal to 2x
plus 1 where X is the number of books so
now to solve this equation all we have
to do is subtract one from both sides so
we have 19 is equal to 2x divide both
sides by 2 and you can see that X is
coming out to 9.5 now you might be
tempted to round up because this is of
0.5 and say that's 10 books but
obviously if you were to buy 10 books 2
times 10 is 20 plus 1 is 21 you've
exceeded your budget so in this case we
have to round down the most number of
books that we could buy would be nine
books and you can see that the slope
here this is like y equals MX plus b
this number in front of the x is like
the slope or the rate or the cost per
book whereas the one that's like the
initial condition the starting amount or
in this case probably what it costs to
purchase this canvas bag so kind of an
easy problem just understanding function
notation
for number eight it says you have two
dollars and fifty cents in your pocket
consisting of just dimes and quarters
write a linear equation in standard form
and interpret the intercepts of the
graph okay so what does that mean a
linear equation in standard form well
that's an equation of the form ax plus b
y equals c so what we could do is we
could say let's let the number of Dimes
be X and let's let the number of
quarters be y okay so what we could say
is it looks like a dime is 10 cents so
we could say 10 cents times the number
of Dimes X plus a quarter which is 25
cents times the number of quarters
equals the total two dollars and fifty
cents now oftentimes when we write an
equation in this standard form it's good
to have a b and c to be just integer
values so if we were to multiply
everything by 100 that's going to move
this decimal two places to the right and
so it's a little bit neater form here so
10x plus 25y is equal to 250. now this
is our equation but we want to do is we
want to enter interpret the intercepts
so if we were to draw a graph
of this situation what we could do is we
could say well hmm if
X is zero okay y would be 10 right so
let's just say that this is uh 10 over
here so let's say 5 10.
okay and Y represents the number of
quarters now if Y is 0
X is equal to 25 so 5 10 15 20 25.
okay so now this is our graph and what
do these intercepts mean well we said Y
is the number of quarters X is the
number of Dimes so if we're right here
at this y-intercept what that tells us
is that we have all quarters
and no dimes whereas over here 25 this
x-intercept which is all dimes and no
quarters so what you're doing by finding
the intercepts is you're setting one of
the variables equal to zero I oftentimes
make a table like this x is 0 or Y is
zero and so it's all of one and none of
the other so great job if you could do
that one okay if you're still with me
see if you can do numbers 9 through 12.
so these problems should be getting more
challenging as we get further into the
year with algebra one the first few I
know are kind of easy because you know
you're just getting started with algebra
one but for number nine it says you head
home
from work at a constant rate of speed of
50 miles an hour your job is 10 miles
from home write a function that gives
the distance D that you are from home as
a function of the time T in hours and
interpret the slope M and the
y-intercept B so how would you do that
one well if I was going to do this
problem we're saying that distance d
is a function of the time T in hours and
you can see what we're doing is we're
actually getting closer and closer to
home so this is actually like the
distance is decreasing as time goes by
so I would write this as a negative 50 t
plus 10. and so what this represents is
you can see for example if like you were
traveling for
let's just say it was like
a fifth of an hour right so a fifth of
an hour that would be one-fifth times
negative 50 is negative ten plus ten is
zero you'd be at home right but the
reason we have this slope here as a
negative is because it's the distance is
decreasing so when you think of the
slope that's the rate in this case the
rate of change we want that to be
negative because you're getting closer
the distance is getting smaller the b or
the y-intercept that's like our initial
condition or starting amount we're
actually 10 miles from home so when T
equals zero you're 10 miles away but as
T increases the distance is actually
getting smaller smaller you're getting
closer to home so this is just
practicing writing equations in slope
intercept form and the function notation
let's go on to these ones here now 10 11
12. it says write G in terms of F and
describe the transformation from F to G
so here we're given the function f of x
equals X Plus 1 and then G of X is equal
to Negative X plus one how do we get
from this function to this function well
you can see that g of X is equal to f of
negative X so what I what you do here is
whatever is in the parentheses that goes
in for X on the right and you can see
here we have Negative X so we're
replacing x with negative X which is how
we're getting this function here
Negative X plus one so that's writing G
in terms of f but what is this f of
negative X actually do to our graph well
when you're multiplying all the X values
by negative 1
what that does is it makes all these
that are on the right side go to the
left and all the left that are on the
right so it's a reflection over the
y-axis so I'm just going to write
reflection over the y-axis okay for
number 11 What's Happening Here f of x
equals 3x minus 2 G of x equals 6X minus
four how are we getting from the F
function to the G function
well if I was going to do this one I
would say G of X is equal to F of
actually that's not right G of X is
equal to
2 times f of x 2 times f of x so what's
happening is we're basically taking this
function we're multiplying the entire
thing by 2
and so what is this 2 here in front of f
of x do well when you think of f of x
these are like the Y values and if you
double the Y values that's a vertical
stretch by a factor of 2. so I'll just
abbreviate vertical stretch
by Factor
of 2. okay and then for the number 12
this last one f of x is equal to 6X plus
2 G of X our new function is equal to 3x
plus 2 how are we getting from f of x to
G of X well you can see here that
G of X is equal to F of
half X so what's happening remember wave
functions work is whatever is in
parentheses is going for in for X on the
right so I'm replacing x with one half x
6 times 1 half X is giving us the 3x
notice the 2 is staying the same so
we're not multiplying the entire
equation like we did in this last one
okay by a factor we're just replacing x
with one half X and when you look at
this at first glance you'd say well if
all the X values are half as much that's
a horizontal shrink but remember when
it's grouped with the X it has the
opposite of factor or the reciprocal
effect it's actually multiplying the X's
by a factor of two and this is a
horizontal stretch by a factor of two so
number 12 horizontal stretch by a factor
of two and you got it and this is the
notation so these ones are a little bit
more challenging Transformations great
job if you're able to get those okay see
if you can pause the video and do number
13 and number 14. for number 13 it says
describe the transformation from f of x
equals the absolute value of x to G of x
equals the absolute value of the
quantity 2x minus two plus one and then
graph it
so if I was going to do this problem
what I would do is I would work from the
inside out and what I mean by that is I
try to build up this function from this
basic parent function the absolute value
of x so what I would start off with is I
would start off with saying that okay
the absolute value of x and I'm
replacing that with
absolute value of x minus 2. then what
I'm doing is I'm replacing this x here
with the quantity 2X
and then what we're doing is we're
adding one so if you follow those steps
what's happening is you're Shifting the
graph right to remember the one group
with the X has the opposite effect so
this would go right to then we're
replacing x with 2X and when it's
grouped with the X like that it has the
reciprocal effect so it looks like
you're multiplying the X's by two this
is actually a horizontal shrink by a
factor of 2. and then you're Shifting
the graph up one
now let's take a look at the basic
absolute value graph if we just plot
some easy numbers here like negative 2
the absolute value of negative 2 is
positive 2. remember the absolute value
always makes the quantity positive right
but then if we're shifting right to what
that does is it adds two to all these X
values so these would now become 0 1 2 3
and 4. Let's cross out those old ones
and then we said we're doing a
horizontal shrink by a factor of one
half so we're going to multiply all the
X values by one half
so that's going to be 0 1 half 1 3
halves and two
and then the plus one that's Shifting
the graph up one which is adding one to
the Y value so this is going to be three
two one two and three
now when we plot this let's see it looks
like we have 0 3 which is right here
let's see one half which is at two
one one
a one and a half comma two
and two comma three so approximately
right there so you can see there's your
V shape graph
and another way to do this problem just
as far as rewriting this you could
actually factor a 2 out I think a lot of
students might prefer to do it this way
and what happens now is you can see this
is a vertical stretch by a factor of two
this is going to shift it right one and
then up one so a little bit easier way
to do it but if you want to kind of
interpret the Transformations as it's
given here that's how I would that's how
I would do it so let's look at number 14
now it says write a linear function with
the given values okay so again we're
coming back to function notation
remember whatever is in the parentheses
this is like your input or your x value
and whatever comes out this is like your
y value so in a sense what they're doing
is they're giving us two coordinates X
comma y
and X comma y so in order to find the
equation of this line what we have to do
is find the slope and remember the slope
formula it's Y2 minus y1
over X2 minus X1
and if we simplify Remember When You
Subtract it's like adding the opposite
so that's 15 over negative 7. that's our
slope and we can write this as y equals
MX plus b so if negative 15 7 X plus b
now B is our y-intercept how do we find
the y-intercept well we know goes
through both of these points let's just
use this first point right here we'll
substitute negative 6 in for Y 2 in for
x
and remember 2 is like 2 over 1 that
helps to kind of line things up a little
bit and we can solve for our B value so
this comes out to negative 37.
negative 6 is if we multiply the top and
bottom by 7 that's going to come out to
negative 42 7 and now all we have to do
is add 37 to this side which is going to
give us negative 12 7 is equal to B now
we can take that put it back in for B
and let's write it in the f of x
notation the function notation so that
would be f of x is equal to negative 15
7 x minus 12 7. and you got it see if
you can do number 15 and number 16. so
for 15 it says you purchase tickets for
a concert through a ticket Processing
Company it costs 250 to 252 dollars for
five tickets and 156 dollars for three
tickets how much is one ticket and what
is the processing fee per order so how
do you think you would do that one well
one way I like to look at these types of
problems is to coronatize the
information what I mean by that is see
how five tickets uh cost 252 dollars
we're turning that into like a x y
coordinate and three tickets costs
156 dollars
okay so now you can see we've got these
two points and we can write the equation
of a line so we're going to find our
slope by doing a Y2 minus y1 so 252
minus 156 over X2 minus X1 that's 5
minus three
and if we simplify that let's go to the
calculator here we've got 252 minus 156
it's 96.
divided by 2 so that comes out to 48.
now when you write the equation of a
line you can use the slope intercept
form or the point-slope form let's go
ahead and do the point-slope formula
let's use this point right here so we
say y minus y1 which is 156 is equal to
the slope which is 48 times x minus X1
that's the x coordinate of the point
let's rearrange it into slope intercept
form by Distributing the 48 so that's
going to come out to 48x minus 144
and then we're just going to add the 156
to the other side if we do that let's
see what we get 48x let's see uh 24 plus
one so that's coming out to 12.
and so now this is the equation of our
line but what we want to do is we want
to answer the question what's the price
per ticket and the cost of the
processing per order remember the slope
is like the the rate in this case it's
the rate per ticket the cost per ticket
so 48 dollars per ticket
and then the B is the y-intercept or the
initial condition or the starting amount
or the fixed cost in this case this
would be the processing fee so twelve
dollars for the processing fee and then
48 dollars for each additional ticket so
that would be how you would solve that
one for number 16 it says for what value
of K that's this K right here are the
lines parallel and then what for what
value of the of K are the lines
perpendicular so what we need to do on
this problem is we need to figure out
what the slope of this line is so we're
going to divide both sides by five
okay everything by five so that comes
out to y equals negative three-fifths X
plus seven fifths this is in the slope
intercept form y equals MX plus b form
that number that comes in front of the x
or to the left of the X that's our slope
and over here let's rearrange this one
by dividing everything by four
to put this into the Y equals MX plus b
form slope intercept form
and now you can see this is the slope of
this line
now in order for the lines to be
parallel that cross right that means
they have to be going up at the same
slope okay or in this case it's a
negative they're going down at the same
rate and so in order for the lines to be
parallel the slopes have to be equal to
each other so negative three-fifths
would have to equal K over 4. so what we
can do now is multiply both sides by 4
to get K by itself that's like
multiplying by four over one and that's
coming out to negative 12 fifths equals
K if you want the lines to be parallel
now if you want to be perpendicular then
the slopes are opposite reciprocals of
one another so what I mean by that is if
this slope's negative three-fifths the
opposite reciprocal you'd flip it and
change the sign to the opposite so from
negative to positive and now we're going
to set that equal to the slope of this
line K over 4 do the same thing multiply
both sides by 4
to get K by itself and you can see
that's coming out to 20 over three
if you want the lines
to be perpendicular okay see if you can
do number 17 and number 18 for 17 it
says write an equation for the nth term
of the arithmetic sequence for the
number of bricks in the nth row find the
number of bricks in the 30th row
okay so you can see that the first row
there's one brick in the second row
there's three bricks then five then
seven then nine Etc so an arithmetic
sequence means that you're adding the
same thing each time to get to the next
term next term next term next term and
in this case you can see that we're
adding two additional bricks when we go
down to the next row next row next row
and remember the formula for an
arithmetic sequence is this guy right
here it's a sub n the value of the nth
term equals a sub 1 the value of the
first term plus n minus 1 times D which
D is our common difference that's what
we're adding to get to the next term or
they call it the difference because
three minus one that's the difference
that's two five minus three is two so
you can see it's going up by two each
time
and the first term the first row has one
brick in it and now we have a formula to
find
how many bricks are in the nth row now
we might want to simplify a little bit
by Distributing this would give us two n
minus two and we can combine like terms
so that's going to be 2N minus one and
now we've got a formula to find how many
bricks are in a given row if we want to
find out how many are in the 30th row
we're just going to replace and with 30
and we can write this as a sub 30 equals
2 times 30 is 60 minus one equals 59
bricks in the 30th row
okay for number 18 this one says write a
piecewise function for the absolute
value function y equals negative 2
absolute value of x minus 1 plus 2. now
what you might want to do is graph this
first just to get a feel for what this
looks like
you can see the minus 1 is going to
shift this graph to the right one and
the plus 2 is going to shift it up two
you can kind of think of that as your
new starting point and then the negative
2 is going to make it open down and it's
going to stretch it you can kind of
think of the two as like the slope it's
basically going down to over one and
then also the other direction so what we
have here is an absolute value graph
that looks something like this
but what you want to do now is you want
to write this in two parts a piecewise
function so we basically we have a line
here
okay when X is less than one and then we
have this other line right here
when X is greater than one so how do we
write that let's write it f of x which
represents our y value
bracket
equals this line right here which this
line you can see it has a slope of 2 and
has a y intercept of zero so that's
going to be
2x plus 0 or just 2x when X is less than
we'll say less than or equal to positive
one so to the left of 1 or equal to one
and then we'll say for this other graph
here this is going to have a negative
two slope see down two over one
and the Y intercept here is 4 but that's
when X is greater than meaning to the
right of one so all we're really doing
is we're just breaking up into two parts
the
line here to the left of one and the
line here to the right of one and that's
a piecewise function okay see if you can
do number 19 and number 20. we've got
some more story problems here it says
you sell a paperback version of your
cookbook for ten dollars and a hardcover
copy for eighteen dollars if you collect
246 dollars total and sell 19 books
total how many of each did you sell so
how would you do that one see if you can
pause the video if I was going to do
this one I would think of the number of
paperbacks plus the number of hardcover
books equals 19 and then I'd say it's
ten dollars for a paperback and there's
it's let's see how much eighteen dollars
for a hardcover copy and you collect a
total of 246 dollars so when you have
two unknowns two you need two variables
and two equations and I like to use that
first letter of the variable like P for
paperback H for hardcover you can use X
and Y but sometimes it's a little bit
easier just to kind of organize your
your thoughts
I would solve this system you can either
do it by substitution elimination
graphing when the variables are on the
left like that and the numbers are on
the right I like to just do the
elimination method so what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to multiply this
top equation by negative 10. and the
reason I'm doing that is so that when I
add it to this bottom equation the P's
will cancel so that's negative 10p minus
10 H equals negative 190
and if we add straight down we said the
P's cancel that comes out to 8 H is
equal to
56 and if we divide both sides by 8 you
can see that you're selling seven hard
copies and if you plug that 7 back into
any one of the equations I'll just do
this one right here P plus 7 equals 19.
subtract 7 from both sides and you can
see the number of paperbacks that you're
selling is 12 and you've got it so let's
go to number 20 now it says you're
mixing a 10 acid solution with a 40 acid
solution how much of each should you mix
to make 10 gallons of a 35 acid solution
now with this problem again we have two
unknowns we have how much we're going to
mix of the 10 acid solution which let's
just call that X and the 40 uh solution
let's call that y so we kind of remember
here so 10 and 40 percent and we're
trying to get 10 gallons of a 35 percent
so what I would do here is I'd make a
little table just to kind of organize
our thoughts and I'd say okay if you
have uh X gallons
of the 10 solution so we're looking at
the quantity times the percentage equals
the amount of pure
acid okay
and so when we multiply those together
we get point one zero X and if we do the
same thing with the 40 percent so we
have y gallons of the 40 solution okay
multiply those together that's the
amount of pure acid and then we want to
end up with 10 gallons of a 35 solution
so that's going to come out to 3.5
gallons of pure acid so it's just a way
of organizing the information in a table
like that you don't have to do it that
way but you can see here when we look at
the quantity here we have a total of 10
gallons so we have X Plus y equals 10.
and if we look at the pure asset
equation right here we have 0.10 X Plus
0.40 y equals 3.5 so we have two
variables two equations we can solve the
system but the first thing I would do is
I would clear the decimals and the way
we can do that in this problem is if we
multiply everything by 10 that moves
that decimal point one place to the
right which now gives us just 1X
plus 4y equals 35 so a little bit easier
to work with and then what I would do is
I would let's subtract these equations
so we'll do I'll do the bottom equation
minus the top so x minus X is zero four
y minus 1y is 3y and 35 minus 10 is 25.
so now if we divide both sides by 3 y
equals 25 thirds which is how much
that's 8
and 1 3
gallons
of the 40 solution
and then if we put that back into this
equation you can put it into either one
you can see that X Plus 8 1 3 equals 10
so that means that X must be one and
two-thirds
gallons of the 10
acid solution and you got it okay before
we dive into number 21 and 22 we've
reached a halfway point so great job if
you've stuck with it this far and let me
know are these questions a little bit
too easy I try to make them kind of
challenging to kind of test you know
where you're at if they are too
challenging go back to my Algebra 1
final exam review and go through that
for some more typical type test problems
these are you know a little bit more
challenging
so let's keep going let's go to number
21 here it says y equals 2x plus 5 and
ax plus 3y equals 18 for what value of a
let's just say right here does the
system have no solution
well when you think about a system of
linear equations that has no solution
that's when the lines are parallel they
don't cross so there's not a common
point of intersection right so what we
need to do is we need to figure out
let's rearrange this what's the slope of
this line so if I subtract Ax from both
sides that's going to be 3y equals
negative ax plus 18. negative because
we're moving to the other side or
subtracting so now I'm going to divide
everything by 3
this is to get that y by itself now it's
in the slope intercept form so we have y
equals negative a over three X plus six
and this number here that comes in front
of the axis is our slope and here you
can see the slope is 2 and we want them
to have the same slope but different
y-intercepts this y intercepts 5 this
inter Y intercept 6. so if they have the
same slope but different y intercepts
they're never going to cross so what
we're going to do is we're going to set
the slopes here equal so we can solve
for a so negative a over 3 is equal to
2. If I multiply both sides by negative
you can see this is going to come out to
a equals negative 6. so if a is negative
6 there's no solution okay for number 22
we have a big one here it says you earn
twelve dollars per hour at Job X and you
have to work a minimum of 15 hours per
week you also work at Job y for twenty
dollars per hour and you want to earn at
least three hundred fifty dollars per
week but you want to work no more than
30 hours per week writing graph a system
of linear inequalities and identify a
solution Okay so we've got two jobs X
and Y and you can see one job pays more
twenty dollars one pays less twelve
dollars per hour so what are our
inequalities well let's start off by
saying you want to work a minimum of
you know we have to work a minimum of 15
hours at jobac so that means that the
number of hours that job X has to be
greater than or equal to 15. okay so if
we were to graph that
x equals lines remember these are
vertical lines like this and greater
than means it would be to the right so
I'll just draw a little arrow to show
that we're going to be shading to the
right there
you also want to keep in mind that you
can't work a negative number of hours so
the number of hours that job X has to be
greater than or equal to zero and the
number of hours that job y has to be
greater than or equal to zero which
greater than or equal to zero that's the
y-axis that's over here and then Y is
x axis that's above here so that puts us
in the first quadrant
okay now you want to earn at least 350
dollars per week so let's see what is
that equation well it be 12 dollars
times the number of hours at Job X plus
20 y has to be greater than or equal to
350. and we also want to work no more
than 30 hours so that's X Plus Y is less
than or equal to 30. Okay so we've got a
lot of inequalities here we want to
graph that and see where these overlap
so let's take a look here let's do this
One X Plus Y is less than or equal to
30. so when x is 0 y would be 30
and when Y is 0 x is 30. so I'm just
using the intercept method and if I was
to draw this it's going to be a line
kind of like that it should be a
straight line okay and when you do the
test Point method like 0 0 like the
origin is 0 less than or equal to 30 yes
so that means we're shading on this side
of the line so I'm just going to draw a
little arrow so we know and then this
one here let's do the same thing if x is
350 divided by 20 is how much
that's 17.5 so our y-intercept is like
right about here and if Y is 0 What's
350 divided by 12
that's
29.2 roughly so that's going to put you
right about here so if we try to draw a
straight line of course I don't have a
ruler here I'm just eyeing this here I'm
doing it by hand and this one you want
it to be greater than or equal to so if
I was to pick a test Point like 0 0
that's right here is that greater than
or equal to 350 no so we want to shade
on the other side of the line so I'm
going to draw an arrow like this so you
can see what we have here now we have to
be above this line below this line to
the right of this line
that's going to put us right in this
region right here
so as long as we're in that region we're
going to satisfy all these constraints
but we want to just find out what is a
solution so a point that's in this
region well
we're not trying to optimize necessarily
here that's a little different kind of a
problem we're just trying to find a
point that makes up all these
inequalities true so let's just say for
example maybe 15
hours at Job X and
let's see uh
what would be another possibility here
maybe like
about 12 hours a job y so we could say
15 hours at X and 12 hours
at Y and you can you know this graph is
kind of rough so you can kind of check
it 15 plus 12 that's 27 that's less than
or equal to 30. 12 times 15 is 180
plus 20 times 12 that's 3 that's 240 so
that comes out to how much 180 plus 240
that's 400 so that's more than 350 and
these are both going to be greater than
zero and the number of hours at X is uh
greater than because of 15 that's
exactly 15. so this would be one
possible solution in this region here
okay see if you can do number 23 and 24
go ahead and pause the video uh if I was
going to do this problem we've got a lot
of exponents here so how do we approach
this this is really testing us on our
rules of exponents the first thing I
probably would do here is I probably try
to simplify the inside so I would say
when you divide you subtract the
exponents so 5 minus negative 3 that's
like five plus three so that's going to
give us 2 x to the eighth y to the
second all raised to the second power
over here anything to the zero power
that's one okay and one times anything
is itself and then here when we divide
divide we subtract right so negative 3
minus one see if there's a one there
there's not an exponent written so
negative 3 minus 1 is X to the negative
fourth
and this is over 3 y to the negative
fourth all raised to the negative second
okay so now what we can do is power to
power you multiply now if you don't see
an exponent there's always a one so
power to power we're going to multiply
all these exponents by two so two
squared is four
x to the 16th y to the fourth
times and now here we have x to the
eighth
3 to the negative 2 power and Y to the
eighth now remember when you have a
negative exponent you can take the
reciprocal you can move this to the
other side of the fraction bar make it a
positive exponent but I think before I
do that I would think of this as a
fraction over one I'm just going to
multiply across here so 4 times 1 is 4 x
to the 16 times x to the eighth is X to
the 24th and then we have y to the
fourth and then in the denominator one
times anything is itself so we have 3 to
the negative second y to the eighth now
this 3 to the negative second we don't
want a negative exponent or final answer
I'm going to move that up to the
numerator that's going to be 3 squared
so let's just write that as 3 squared
which is 9 9 times 4 is 36
x to the 24th
and then when you divide here you
subtract or you can think of four of
these y's canceling before these y's
leaving 4 left over in the denominator
and you got it
okay for number 24 it says evaluate 81
to the negative 3 4. so if you remember
your rational exponents these fractional
exponents like a ratio
this is really referring to the root and
this is referring to the power and the
negative tells us to take the reciprocal
so this is like 1 over 81 to the 3 4
power or we could say this 4 is the
fourth root of 81
cubed now you can put the
3 on the inside or the outside let's do
it like that
the fourth root of 81 what number times
itself 4 times is 81 well that would be
three
3 cubed is 3 times 3 times 3 that's 27
so this is going to come out to 1 over
27. now you can do this another way you
could do the negative at the very end
you could say the fourth root of 81 is
three three cubed is 27 and the negative
take the reciprocal and you get the same
result okay see if you can do number 25
and 26 it says graph f of x equals
negative 3 times 1 half to the x minus 1
power plus two so this is an exponential
function how would you graph it
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem one way to do it is to
think about the translation of right one
and up two remember the one that's
grouped with the x that has the opposite
effect so minus one is going to shift it
right one the plus two is going to shift
it up two we can think of this as like
our new starting point
and this is where also where our
horizontal asymptote is going to be so
this plus two shifts shift the graph up
to shifts the horizontal asymptote up
too then we can focus on this parent
function here
y equals negative 3
times one half to the X so let's make a
little table
and see what this looks like so let's
say if we put in negative one zero and
one
a one-half to the negative one when it's
a negative exponent you take the
reciprocal so that'd be two times
negative 3 is negative six one half to
the zero is one times negative three is
negative three and then one half to the
first is one-half times negative three
is negative three halves but we're going
to plot it not from the original origin
but this shifted origin so I'm going to
go left one down six which is right here
0 negative 3 which is right here and
right one down one and a half which is
right about here and so you can see this
graph is
looking something like this
and you got it horizontal asymptote at y
equals two and domain is all real
numbers the range would be Y is less
than two okay see if you can do number
this one says rewrite the exponential
function and identify the percent rate
of growth or Decay now you probably
remember learning about the exponential
growth model or exponential decay model
it was in this form right here it's a y
equals a times 1 plus r to the T or 1
minus r to the T the r is the rate of
growth or rate of Decay if it's bigger
than one it's going to be a growth if
it's you know less than one it's going
to be Decay and the a is like the
starting amount and then T is like the
time okay so what we need to do though
is see it's not in this form we have the
set of T we have t divided by three so
let's go ahead and rewrite this a little
bit let's say this is uh 0.76
to the one third and that's all raised
to the T power now what I'm doing is I'm
making use of the rules of exponents
when you have a power to a power what do
you do you multiply and that's going to
give us back this T divided by 3.
so let's go to the calculator now let's
see what is 0.76 raised to the one-third
power that's coming out to 0.91
approximately I'm going to round so this
is 4 times 0.91 to the T now when you
look at this base here this 0.91 you can
see it's less than 1 by how much well
let's write it a little bit differently
let's write it as 1 minus
.09 to the T see 1 is like a hundred
percent minus nine percent equals 91
percent so this is a nine percent
rate
of
decay
and you got it now if this came out to
let's say
1.25 then it would be a 25 rate of
growth the sofa was more than one okay
see if you can pause the video and do
number 27 and number 28. for 27 it looks
like we're dealing with some exponents
here what I would do is I would try to
get the basis to be the same for both
the left and the right side and then we
can set the powers equal to each other
so here 3 the cube root of 3 is really
like 3 to the one third power remember
the index or the root goes in the
denominator and the numerator the power
goes in the in the top the the top is
the power or the exponent
so now what you have is you have a power
to power which you're going to multiply
these together let's look at the other
side so 127 that's really like 3 to the
negative third
all raised to the negative X plus four
and again power to power we multiply
we've got the same base of 3 so as long
as the bases are the same that means the
exponents are going to be equal to each
other so we're going to set these equal
to each other
one-third times two x minus 1 is equal
to negative three
times negative X plus four let's go
ahead and distribute that comes out to 2
3 x minus one-third equals positive
three x minus 12. we can multiply
everything by 3 to clear the fractions
that's going to come out to 2x minus 1
equals 9x minus 36 and then now let's
see if we subtract 2x that'll be 7x if
we add 36 that'll be 35 and if we divide
both sides by 7 you can see that X is
coming out to 5.
okay for number 28 now what is the 13th
term of the geometric sequence where the
fourth term is 25 and the common ratio
is equal to 5. well sometimes on a
problem like this you can diagram it out
a little bit like if they tell us the
fourth term is 25
and the ratio is five what that means is
we're multiplying by five each time so
this would be 125 625
Etc
but when we find a formula for any term
in a geometric sequence we use this
formula here a sub n equals a sub 1
times R to the N minus 1 power
we need to know what the first term is
so what we could do is we could say well
if I'm multiplying by 5 this way I would
be dividing by 5 if I go backwards here
so this would be 5 1 1 5. so now we know
okay there's our value of our first term
one-fifth we know we're multiplying by
five
to the N minus 1 power so this is a
formula for finding any term in the
sequence if we want the 13th term we'll
replace n with 13.
and let's see what that comes out to 13
minus 1 is 12.
and let's go to the calculator so we've
got one fifth
let's see times 5 to the 12th Power is
coming out to
four eight eight two eight one two five
so that would be forty eight million 828
125.
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 29 and 30. it says write the
first five terms of the recursive
sequence given here and how would you do
that well notice they're telling us that
the first term is five
and then the value of the second term is
three and then we have this like
recursive formula or rule for finding
the next term next term next term now
notice this pattern see the value of the
term this is a sub 1 the value of this
term is a sub 2 but the term number is n
equals one n equals two n equals three
so what this is telling us is we're
going to take two times a sub n minus 2.
now if we want the third term see a sub
3 3 minus two would be one so we'd go
back to the first term which is five and
we'd multiply that by two so that's ten
minus three times three minus 1 which is
the second term two okay and we're
multiplying that by negative three so
negative 3 times 3 is negative 9. so 10
minus nine is one now that might sound a
little bit confusing so you can either
plug in 3 and for both these ends okay
and then find out what terms you're
dealing with or another way to look at
it like say if I wanted to find this
fourth term the N minus 2 tells me I go
back two terms
and the N minus 1 means I go back one
term okay so in this case if I say all
right I want the fourth term so I'm
going to take
2 times the term 2 back so 2 times 3
which is 6
minus 3 times the term 1 back so 3 times
1 is 3 6 minus 3 is 3. now for the fifth
term I'm going to go 2 back so that's
one so two times one is two minus 3
times the one the term one back which is
this three here so we're getting two
minus 9 which is negative seven
and you got it
okay for number 30 it says you want to
double the area of your rectangular
patio that's eight feet by 12 feet by
adding the same amount to the width and
the length what are the New Dimensions
so let's draw a little diagram that's
always helpful so you have this
rectangular patio that's eight feet by
12 feet you're going to add X here and
you're going to add X here and so now
it's a little bit bigger and you're
basically doubling the the area so 8
times 12 the original area was 96 the
new area is going to be twice that which
is 192 total so what's the formula for
the area of a rectangle it's going to be
length times width so this is going to
be X plus 12 times X Plus 8 is equal to
this 192. so let's go ahead and multiply
this out we get x squared plus 8X plus
12x
plus 96 is equal to 192. we'll subtract
combine like terms
and 96 minus 192 is negative 96.
equals zero okay so now all we have to
do is Factor this and set the factors to
zero so what multiplies to negative 96
but adds to 20. that would be positive
24 and negative 4 and now if we set both
of these factors equal to zero we get X
plus 24 equals zero so x equals negative
24 but we really can't have a negative
24 like as a dimension or a length and
then over here we have x minus 4 equals
0 add 4 to both sides x equals four so
that would be a good answer so you're
just adding 4 feet to the width and the
length Okay see if you can do number 31
and 32 for 31 it says Factor this
completely now when you see this factor
completely usually that's implying that
there might be more than one
step in the factory you might have to
factor multiple times so for this one
the first step in factoring is always
the greatest common factor so you look
and say is there something I can factor
out of all the terms well it looks like
we could factor out a three so that
would leave us with X to the fifth
plus 2X to the fourth minus 16x
minus 32. okay now when you have four
terms usually you try to see if you can
Factor by grouping so what I would do is
I would group these first two terms
together and these last two terms
together and factor out a greatest
common factor out of each of the two
groups so here I can factor out an x to
the fourth and that would leave us with
X plus two here I can factor out a
negative 16 and that also leaves us with
X plus two and so by factoring out this
X plus 2 out of this group and this
group we're left with X to the fourth
minus sixteen
times X plus two and don't forget about
the three let's bring that down in front
now can we Factor this further
well we can see we have a difference of
two perfect squares and we can factor
that as a sum and difference pattern so
take the square root of x to the fourth
which is x squared
okay and take the square root of 16
which is four and one's positive and
one's negative let's bring down this X
plus 2 here
and let's bring down the three now can
we Factor further well you can see x
squared minus 4 is also a difference of
two squares this is a sum of two squares
you really can't factor that so this
here is going to factor to X plus two
x minus 2
and then we have X plus 2X minus 2 and
then this X plus 2 as well which I'm
going to write this as X plus 2 squared
since we have two of those x squared
plus 4 and then we bring down the 3. can
we factor that further it looks like
that's as far as we can go so you you
got it
okay for number 32
they're giving us this equation here
that models the height and feet of a
thrown object after T seconds will the
object clear a 24 foot fence and when
will it hit the ground so really two
questions in one right so when will the
object clear a 24 foot fence well you're
throwing it up in the air
and so really what we're looking for is
like what's that maximum height and that
maximum height is going to occur at the
vertex notice that a is negative that's
how we know it's opening down this
Parabola this quadratic how do we find
the vertex well remember the formula
negative B over 2A that gives us the x
coordinate of the vertex and then if we
plug it back in we can get the y
coordinate which would represent the
height
so negative B that's the opposite of 32
over 2 times a which is negative 16.
that comes out to negative 32 over
negative 32 which is 1. so basically
after one second it's going to reach the
maximum height now if I plug one back in
that comes out to what that comes out to
negative 16 times 1 squared is 1 plus 32
times 1 is 32 plus 4. so negative 16
plus 32 is 16 plus 4 is 20 feet so would
it clear a 24 foot fence the answer to
that question is no it would not because
the highest it goes is 20 feet
but when will it hit the ground
well when it hits the ground what's the
height well the height is going to be
equal to zero so we need to figure out
when is this going to be equal to zero
well we can do this a couple different
ways we could graph it and see where it
crosses the x-axis we could try to
factor it and set the factors to zero we
could do completing the square we could
do quadratic formula a lot of different
techniques let's see what we can do here
let's go ahead and subtract the 4 to the
other side
so that's going to get we're going to
move this 4 over here then I'm going to
factor out a negative 16 T out of both
of these terms no I'm just going to
factor out a negative 16 and that'll
give us let's see t squared minus 2T
okay now what we're going to do is we're
going to complete the square so we're
going to say hmm
half of
negative 2 is negative 1. negative 1
squared is 1.
but we're adding 1 to the right side of
the equation it's actually negative 16
times a 1 which is negative 16 we're
adding to the right so we have to add a
negative 16 to the left to keep this
balanced so this is negative 20.
is equal to
ah
not okay so is equal to negative 16 and
if we Factor this this factors to T
minus 1 squared okay so now we're going
to do is we're going to divide both
sides by negative 16.
and that we can divide the top and
bottom by negative four so this comes
out to 5 4 is equal to T minus 1 the
quantity squared and we've completed the
square we're just going to take the
square root of both sides
okay so the the square and the square
root cancel so this comes out to T minus
1 is equal to plus or minus remember
when you take the square root of both
sides get two answers the square root of
over the square root of 4 which is just
2 and if I add 1 to both sides we get 1
Pulsar minus square root of 5 over 2.
now let's see what is square root of 5
over 2
that is
about 1.12 so this is one plus or minus
1.12 now if we do 1 minus 1.12 that's
going to be a negative time that's like
going back in time so that that doesn't
make sense so let's just do the 1 plus
1.12 that comes out to 2.12 seconds it's
going to hit the ground okay see if you
can do number 33 and 34 go ahead and
pause the video and if I was going to do
this one it says rewrite the quadratic
and vertex form
okay and so how exactly would we
approach that well the first thing I
would do is I would subtract 1 from both
sides just to get that constant out of
the way so that gives us y minus 1
equals negative 3x squared minus 6X then
what you want to do is you want to
factor out that leading coefficient just
the negative 3 not the X
so that comes out to x squared plus 2X
plus blank and then what you want to do
to complete the square is you take half
of this B value and you square it so you
say half of 2 is 1 1 squared is one but
because this is in parentheses it's
actually negative 3 times 1 which is
negative 3 that we're adding to the
right side of the equation so we have to
add 3 to the left to keep it balanced
right so this is y minus 4 equals
negative 3 and then now if we Factor
this it's going to factor to X Plus 1
the quantity squared it's always half of
this B value here this is minus 2x would
be minus 1. then we'll just add 4 to the
other side
and now we have it in the vertex form so
this is plus 4 here and you can see the
vertex is going to be at negative 1
comma four it's going to be opening down
because a is negative and it's going to
be stretched but this is the equation in
vertex form
okay so now for number 34 write a cubic
function that passes through the points
given okay so let's just draw a quick
sketch here we can see it's crossing
here at negative 2 0 it's crossing here
at 3 0 crossing here at negative four
zero and at 0 5 right here so what's
interesting is see they're giving us the
three
x-intercepts and what you want to
recognize is that if you have the
x-intercept you can write the factor as
x minus that x-intercept so if this is
negative 4 or negative 2 and 3 this is
going to look like X plus four
X plus 2 x minus 3. see how the factors
are always x minus the the zeros or the
X intercepts but then what we're going
to do is we're going to take this one
step further and we're going to put a
coefficient in front here an a value and
the a value kind of tells us like the
the vertical stretch or Shrink or if it
reflects and we have an additional Point
here that's not one of our x-intercepts
and that's this point here 0 5. so what
we can do is we can put 5 in for f of x
which is like our y value and we could
put 0 in for our X
variables here and if we do that that's
going to give us 4 times 2 times
negative 3 which comes out to negative
24 times a which equals five divide both
sides by negative 24 and you can see a
is equal to negative 5 24.
which we're going to put back in for a
right here so our final equation in
factored form for our cubic okay third
degree equation is going to be negative
5 24
times X plus 4 times X plus 2 times x
minus 3
and you got it now you could foil this
out if you wanted to but we'll just
leave it in factored form for now okay
before we jump into number 35 and 36 if
you like the way that I explain things
and you want to go deeper into Algebra 1
Algebra 2 college algebra check out my
video courses down in the description
below I go into more teaching and
explanation of the different concepts we
do example problems and you have some
opportunities to practice as well so
check out those video courses but let's
keep going with this review and 35 it
says simplify and you can see these are
cube roots so we want to do is we want
to pull out perfect cubes
to simplify these right so 192 I can see
that this is divisible by 3 because the
sum of the digits is 12 and if 12 is by
3 then this whole number divided by 3.
3 goes in there 64 times
and then what I can see is that 64 is a
perfect Cube because 4 times 4 times 4.
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pull a 4 out it's going to get
multiplied by this 2 and we're going to
have 8x
cube root of 3x this 3 is left over this
x is left over
okay now this one
375 this is 125 times 3
and the cube root of 125 is 5 so that's
going to come out in front
and we're left with this 3 underneath
the cube root and then we can make
another group of three axes here so that
would be cube root of x cubed is X with
1X left over now look what we have here
we have eight of this group minus five
of the same kind of groups so 8 minus 5
is going to give us 3
X cube root of 3x and you've simplified
it okay for number 36 it says what
values of c that's this guy right here
gives two real solutions to this
equation now what this problem is
speaking to is the discriminant so
remember the discriminant is the B
squared minus 4AC and if we want two
real solutions the discriminant has to
be positive which is like saying it has
to be greater than zero so let's go
ahead and solve this inequality B
squared would be negative 2 squared
minus 4 times a which is 3 times C which
we don't know and that whole thing has
to be greater than zero so negative 2
squared is four
this comes out to minus 12C
we'll get C by itself here so we'll
subtract 4 from both sides
and we'll divide both sides by negative
12.
and remember when you multiply or divide
both sides by a negative number what
happens to this inequality sign it
changes Direction so this would be C is
less than
one third so as long as C is less than
one-third you're going to have two real
solutions okay see if you can pause the
video and do number 37 and 38 37 we're
solving this non-linear system 38 we're
graphing but for 37 how would you do
this one
well if I was doing this one I would use
the substitution method I would say if Y
is equal to this quantity right here how
about I put it in for y in the second
equation
just remember whenever you do a
substitution it's helpful to put it in
parentheses because you want to treat it
like a group
okay so now what we have is we have one
equation in one variable in terms of X
so we want to just distribute this
negative
excuse me minus 2x squared plus x minus
4 is equal to negative 10. and then
let's go ahead and
get everything on one side and set this
equal to zero so if I add the 2x squared
to the other side
that would be positive 2x squared this
is 4X If I subtract 4X the other side
that's negative 4X and then if I add 4
to the other side that's going to give
me a negative
6 and that's equal to 0. okay now what I
can do is divide everything by 2 so
that's going to be 0 equals x squared
minus 2x minus 3. this we can factor x
minus 3 X plus one and if we set both of
these factors equal to 0 you can see
that we're going to get X is equal to 3
and X is equal to negative 1. now if I
take the 3 I can put it back into this
top equation or this equation here
either one I'll just do the top equation
so if I put in 3 I get 3 squared is 9
times 2 is 18 minus 3 plus 4 so that
comes out to 19
and if I put negative 1 in let's see I
get when negative 1 squared is 1 times 2
is 2 minus negative 1 which is like plus
one plus four that comes out to 7 and
what these represent these are the two
points where these two graphs would
intersect or cross this top one is a
parabola this other one's a line and
basically you're getting two points
where they intersect or cross
okay for number 38 now we're graphing
this square root function how would you
graph that one
there's a lot of different ways to do it
you can make a table you can use a
Transformations one technique that's
nice is you can take whatever's
underneath the square root and set it
equal to numbers that are easy to take
the square root of like zero
one four
and 9.
okay so if we do that you can see this
is going to be X is equal to 1. this one
we're going to be let's see if we
subtract one that would be zero so that
would be X is equal to zero
and then over here we have uh subtract
one that's three
and multiply both sides by negative one
so x equals negative 3 and then here's
subtract one
and divide by negative one so x equals
negative 8. so now what you would do is
you'd make a table
using these values here so you'd start
with the one zero negative 3 negative 8.
so if we put 1 in that's going to be 0
square root of zero is zero times two is
zero plus three is three
if we put 0 in that's going to be 0 plus
1 is 1 the square root of 1 is 1 times 2
is 2 plus 3 is 5. if we put negative
three in we get 4 square root of 4 is 2
2 times 2 is 4 plus 3 is 7 and if we put
in negative eight
we get 9 square root of 9 is 3 times 2
is 6 plus 3 is 9.
now let's go ahead and plot this on our
graph so 1 3 would be right about here 0
5 would be right about there negative 3
7 would be right about here
and negative 8 9 would be right about
four five six seven eight see one two
three four five six seven eight uh nine
would be right about
uh here okay roughly so you can see this
graph basically just goes One Direction
and notice how it's going to the left
that's because this negative X is
reflecting it over the y-axis normally
when you graph the square root graph we
know it looks something like that so
this would be your graph three last two
questions were nearing the end here if
you have any questions about how to
solve some of these problems
um
what you can do is go to my Mars math
tutoring YouTube channel and check out
these different topics I'll have
examples that are similar to a lot of
these problems so you can get some more
experience and practice but for 39 how
would you solve this radical equation
and for number 40 how would you find the
inverse of this function
well for 39 what I want to do is I want
to get one of these square roots by
itself on one side of the equation this
one already is by itself so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to square the
right side and I'm going to square the
left side when I square the square root
those are inverses they cancel right so
this is just going to come out to X Plus
12. over here we have a binomial and
remember when you square a binomial it
really means you have like two of these
groups so you have a 5 minus square root
of x minus 3 and another 5 minus square
root of x minus 3. so we can foil these
together or distribute twice 5 times 5
is 25 this gives us a negative 5 squared
of x minus 3 and over here this gives us
another negative 5 square root of x
minus 3 and then negative square root of
x minus 3 times negative square root of
x minus 3 is a positive
x minus 3
because the square root times itself you
just get what's underneath is equal to X
Plus 12. okay now our goal is to get
these other square roots by themselves
on one side of the equation and square
both sides again so negative 5 and
negative 5 that's going to give us
negative 10 square roots of x minus 3.
25 minus 3 is 22
and if I subtract 22 to the other side
that's going to give us negative 10 and
then over here we've got x and x so if
we
subtract X from both sides those are
going to cancel each other out now if I
divide both sides by negative 10 I get
square root of x minus 3
is equal to 1 and now if we Square the
left side and square the right side to
get rid of this square root we get x
minus 3 equals 1 squared which is 1. ADD
3 to both sides and we get x equals 4.
now we want to be careful when you're
working with these radical equations
because you can get a false answer like
an extraneous root so you want to put it
all the way back in the original problem
and make sure that it's true 4 minus 3
is 1. the square root of 1 is 1. 5 minus
1 is 4 that's the left side 4 over here
4 plus 12 is 16 square root of 16 is 4.
so 4 equals 4 that tells us this is a
good answer
and for this last problem number 40 find
the inverse of this function sometimes
it's helpful to graph it and this is
basically a square root function that's
been shifted right 3 and up 4 and it
would look something like that now
notice the domain is what the X values
can be that would be X is greater than 3
the greater than or equal to the range
is the Y values that could be Y is
greater than or equal to 4. now what's
interesting is
when you find the inverse the domain and
the range switch because you're
switching the X and the Y variables so
in when we find the inverse of this
function our new domain is going to be
what this range was it's going to be
greater than or equal to 4 but it's the
X values okay that are greater than or
equal to 4. so what we're going to do
now is we're going to replace f of x
with Y so this is y equals square root
of x minus 3 plus 4. we're going to
we're going to switch the X and the Y
we're going to Interchange them
and we're going to solve for this new y
so we're going to subtract 4 from both
sides
we're going to square both sides
and if we do that we get y minus 3 is
equal to x minus 4 squared I'll just
leave it like that if we add 3 to both
sides that's going to give us y equals x
minus 4 the quantity squared plus 3. and
you can see this is a parabola in vertex
form the vertex is at 4 3 which would be
right here okay it's opening upward so
it basically looks something like this
okay but we only want the part of the
graph here where X is greater than or
equal to 4. see right over here so we
want where X is greater than equal to 4
that's going to be right here
and greater and you can see if you just
look at that part of the graph let me
erase this part here you can see that
these are reflections over the line Y
equals X that 45 degree line and they're
inverses of one another so a lot of
times students forget to put the
Restriction because really if I was to
graph that entire Parabola like I had
here it fails the horizontal line test
which means that it you know it's not a
the inverse of that graph is not a
function right
so
that's our final answer great job if you
made it through let me know how you did
with this review and follow me over to
my Algebra 1 final exam review where we
go into some more problems that you're
likely to see on your exam I'll see you
over in that video